Les agriculteurs sont
considérés comme des voyous depuis des années.
y a enfin 1 prise de conscience médiatique où je sens,
voilà, on retourne les panneaux,
tout le monde retourne les noms,
c'est formidable.
Mais y a encore pas si longtemps que ça,
c'était quand-même des gens
considérés par l'écologie
punitive comme des gens qui empoisonnent tout le monde,
qui détruisent la nature.
Écoutez, les agriculteurs ont fait exécuter
ce que l'Europe leur a dit depuis toujours,
il y a les
politiques agricoles communes qui sont décidés,
les agriculteurs exécutent.
Comment on peut reprocher à ces gens 1 jour
d'avoir mis en cause la biodiversité
alors qu'ils n'ont fait qu'exécuter
ce qu'on leur a dit ?